I I'm curious originally this was called
Wonderland yes and then you guys change
the title Spectre confidential that was
the motivation for that I don't know I
was that part of the conversation I was
not involved with that was more of
Netflix kind of thing you know they just
thought that this made for a better
title and I certainly didn't mind I
think you know Wonderland as opposed to
you know Spencer fire was the TV series
and then we had the book so I mean I
think it's a it's a it's a happy
compromise what what is taken so I've
talked you a million times and I always
ask you about six billion dollar man how
how is it taken so long to get it off
the ground I think we're about to call
it by the time it comes out we're gonna
call it sixty-year-old six billion
dollar man okay I'll have to change the
title there at least then you'll know
why you know it's one of those things we
just have to get it right I mean build
build the Buick now is writing the
script so I think we have an amazing
idea we'll have an amazing screenplay
we're supposed to get a Friday so I'm
thinking this week and hopefully we'll
then you know pick a start date and a
release date and go make the movie but
like you know Eve uncharted you know I
was attached for years and years to play
Nathan Drake and now I'm playing Sully
and you know even with the fighter you
know I knew there was like a ticking
clock there you know there was a
biological clock so we got to get going
quickly actually you bring up uncharted
2 something that people are very excited
for it's been in development for
literally forever yes um what excites
you about the script you currently have
and when do you start filming and that's
what I guess what you're feeling yeah
yeah start filming in about two weeks
time exciting because it's it's without
giving too much away it's more of like
an origin story so kind of meeting them
and Nathan becoming Nathan and selling
them kind of meeting and kind of trying
to not only get over on each other but
then also starting to partner up and
develop that relationship things would
be very cool it's the first time I feel
like I'm in a movie that's a movie you
know I mean I was like I don't know I
felt like when I read it I was reading
Indiana Jones or Thomas Crown Affair I
mean it's got like these great elements
of these heist movies and and adventure
movies like I've never been apart
couldn't be more excited about